it looks very attractive and black in
particular when black just says okay
this Pawn is on G6 I will not try to get
it out yeah I will just play as if it
doesn't exist
but yeah the the outside passers do
matter a great dealing in games
if kukash really wants to get rid of the
G6 Thorn then could he play F5 maybe and
rookie six over C6
um yeah
I guess this is what he's considering
just trying to solve that issue by
tactical means it's straight away pretty
healthy as far as I can tell yeah we
can't actually I mean we can trade a
five for G6 but that's an improvement
for black yeah and meanwhile we do see
ding resign and Niche jumping up to plus
three
yeah something actually goes back to
minus one
with this loss he started by beating
rukesh with a very in a very very nice
game with black and round one but then
he lost to Prague with